Президенти попри свій статус також опиняються на лаві підсудних.
З них знімають недоторканість і намагаються притягнути до відповідальності.
Кого зі світових лідерів судили за корупцію?
Експрезидент Франції Ніколя Саркозі став першим лідером країни,
який в сучасній історії Франції особисто постав перед судом за звинуваченнями у корупції.
Його визнали винним у спробі підкупу судді та зловживанні службовим становищем.
Саркозі засудили до трьох років позбавлення волі: два умовно й один рік - за ґратами. Він ще має право оскаржити рішення суду.
Гучний процес розпочався наприкінці 2020 року.
Щоправда, Саркозі ще раніше також підозрювали в тому, що він приймав незаконні пожертви
від співвласниці косметичної компанії L'Oreal, мільярдерки Ліліан Бетанкур,
і використовував ці гроші для фінансування своєї передвиборної кампанії в 2007 році.
Саркозі був президентом Франції з 2007-го до 2012-го. Розслідування почалося ще тоді, але Саркозі мав імунітет.
Зрештою у 2013-му вже після його президентства справу закрили за браком доказів.
Саркозі також закидали те, що він отримав фінансову підтримку своєї президентської кампанії
з боку колишнього лівійського лідера Муамара Каддафі.
Крім того, Саркозі та 13 його соратників ще мають постати перед судом у зв'язку з обвинуваченнями
в незаконному фінансуванні своєї президентської кампанії 2012 року.
Експрезидента Франції Жака Ширака, який правив країною з 1995-го до 2007-го, теж судили за корупцію,
але, на відміну від Саркозі, він не з'явився на жодне засідання суду через проблеми зі здоров'ям.
Десять років тому його засудили до двох років ув'язнення умовно за перевищення повноважень і розтрату коштів з громадських фондів.
Ширака звинувачували у створенні фіктивних робочих місць, коли він був мером Парижа.
2019-го експрезидент помер у віці 86 років.
Сільвіо Берлусконі 4 рази був прем'єр-міністром Італії
і отримав чи не найбільше обвинувачень у порушенні закону серед лідерів країн ЄС:
від корупції та зв'язків з мафією до користування послугами неповнолітніх повій.
Берлусконі закидали, що під час так званих вечірок "бунга-бунга" він вступав в інтимні стосунки
з неповнолітньою танцівницею з Марокко на прізвисько Рубі та платив їй за секс.
Крім того, за версією слідства, він зловжив службовим становищем, намагаючись домогтися її звільнення з поліції,
коли Рубі була затримана за підозрою в крадіжці.
"Справу Рубі" та інші Берлусконі вважає брехнею з метою усунення його як політичного конкурента,
а суддів і прокурорів називає "комуністами". У більшості справ проти нього Берлусконі вдавалося відкрутитися.
Тільки у випадку з ухиленням від податків він отримав реальне покарання.
Восени 2012-го його засудили на чотири роки позбавлення волі.
Пізніше покарання було змінено на один рік домашнього арешту.
Три роки тому з нього зняли заборону займати державні посади.
Тож теоретично 84-річний Берлусконі може знову балотуватися.
У 2018-му колишню президентку Південної Кореї Пак Кин Хє засудили на чверть століття за ґратами
за зловживання службовим становищем, здирництво та корупцію.
Спершу їй дали 24 роки, а потім подовжили термін ув’язнення ще на рік.
Крім того, експрезидентка мусила сплатити штраф - у перерахунку майже 18 мільйонів доларів.
За даними слідства, під час перебування на посадіПак Кин Хє примушувала компанії жертвувати мільйони доларів двом фундаціям,
які контролювала її близька подруга Цой Сун Сіль.
Вона не займала офіційних посад, але використовувала свою тісну дружбу з президенткою
для вимагання грошей у великих компаній, зокрема у Samsung, в обмін на начебто політичне заступництво.
Колишній президент Бразилії Мішел ТЕмер, який був при владі у 2016-2019 роках, фігурує одразу в кількох гучних справах.
Зокрема, його обвинувачують у тому, що ставши президентом, він отримав хабар у понад чверть мільйона доларів
через довірених осіб за укладання контрактів при будівництві атомної електростанції.
Також йому закидають керівництво злочинною організацією, яка займалася корупцією.
Розслідування кримінальних справ ще не закінчено.
Двох його попередників - Ділму Русеф та Лулу да Сілву - теж звинувачували у корупції та хабарництві.
Русеф усунули від влади за допомогою імпічменту в 2016-му році,
а наступного року Лулу да Сілву суд визнав винним у корупції та відмиванні грошей і дав йому 9 з половиною років тюрми.
Однак півтора року тому да Сілва вийшов на свободу за рішенням Верховного суду Бразилії.
Міхеіл Саакашвілі був президентом Грузії двічі. І двічі отримував громадянство України.
Спершу від Порошенка, який згодом позбавив його українського паспорта і видворив з країни, а потім від Зеленського.
Нині політик очолює виконком Нацради реформ в Україні.
Тим часом у Грузії Саакашвілі закидають перевищення повноважень і розтрату бюджетних коштів. Низку вироків винесли заочно.
За повідомленнями грузинського мін’юсту, в разі повернення на батьківщину на Саакашвілі чекає ув’язнення.
Він усі звинувачення на свою адресу відкидає.
На початку 2019-го у Києві президента-втікача Віктора Януковича засудили до 13 років позбавлення волі
за державну зраду і пособництво у веденні агресивної війни проти України з боку Росії.
А в травні минулого року заочно арештували як запобіжний захід у справі про зміни до Конституції з метою захоплення влади у 2010-му році.
Януковича та його оточення також обвинувачують у корупції.
Але жодне з кількох десятків кримінальних проваджень досі не завершилося судовим вироком.
Крім того, досі жодного центу з рахунків Януковича та його оточення в європейських банках так і не було повернуто.
Для цього бракує, щонайменше, рішення українських судів про конфіскацію активів колишніх українських можновладців
як таких, що виведені з країни внаслідок розкрадання бюджетних коштів.